The term for
this is patient-centered care.
This may sound like a strange term, but
the traditional health care system is
often been designed and optimized around
the needs of providers, not patients.
As a result, care can be inconvenient.
Patients have to wait for
appointments and
may have to wait even once
they arrive in the clinic.
All of this discourages coming,
particularly for
routine preventative care.
Patient-centered care is designed
around the needs of patients
who may even be able to be seen the same
day they request an appointment.
This care is delivered by a team so
that routine problems that don't require
a physician can be handled by a nurse or
other provider, again, on a much
more convenient and timely basis.
A key tenet of patient-centered care
is that all patients should have
a Primary Care Physician, or PCP.
This is usually a family physician,
general internist or
OB-GYN for adults and
a pediatrician for children.
Their job includes having
a complete view of a patient and
coordinating the care delivered by
the team or even other physicians.
In a well-coordinated healthcare system,
every patient has a PCP.
Since they may not have the skills or
knowledge to manage all of
the problems a patient like Marla has,
part of the PCP's job is to refer
patients to specialists when needed but
still to coordinate and
oversee all of their care.
In this last role,
the PCP is often referred to as
The Gatekeeper, the person who makes
decisions about when their patients
need expensive specialized care.